c'est ce discours a confirmé était ma
position sur steam sont abstenus abstenu
parce que aujourd'hui le gouvernement
commence parce qu'il y a dans ce qu'il
dit des choses intéressantes et alc ont
envie de soutenir
et puis en même temps il ya des points
d'alert en particulier sur les secteurs
sociaux sur les politiques sociales en
particulier donc simplement la
composition du gouvernement indique
quelques interrogations
en particulier le fait qu'il n'est plus
un ministère pour s'occuper des plus
vulnérables des personnes âgées des
familles de l'enfance que tous ces
ministères aient disparu celui chargé
des victimes également suppose que les
politiques sociales soient pour autant
porter parce que là aussi il ya moins de
transformation des politiques sociales
mais que cette évolution
elle doit se faire par mois par une une
jeune changement de méthode
une nouvelle méthode travail social qui
doit être produite et piloter